c'est dans une vidéo de près de 6
minutes diffusé sur son compte twitter
que roanne gouaille de l'opposant
vénézuélien a attiré l'attention du
président nicholas maduro ce mardi
remonté contre la crise que traverse le
venezuela
l'ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale a proposé l'ouverture de
discussions notamment en vue d'établir
un calendrier pour des élections qu'il
qualifie de libre en échange il promet
la levée des sanctions économiques
imposées notamment par les etats-unis le
venezuela a besoin d'accords de salut
national
un accord qui doit être conclu entre les
forces démocratiques représentés par le
gouvernement provisoire l'assemblée
nationale la plateforme unis les acteurs
qui façonnent et soutiennent le
gouvernement et la communauté
internationale une revendication bien
reçu par le président nicolas smad oro
qui lui a répondu sans jamais le nommer
le soir même à la télévision
et bien s'il veut se joindre aux
discussions qui sont déjà en cours
se développant sur tous les sujets il
est le bienvenu pour rejoindre ces
discussions mais pas s'il croit qu'il
est le chef suprême d'un pays qui ne le
reconnaît pas reste à savoir quelle
place sera accordée à wang wei jiafu
dans ce dialogue
son appel intervient quelques jours
après la mise en place du nouveau
conseil national électoral par
l'assemblée nationale
une assemblée dont il a perdu la
présidence en 2020 alors qu'ils avaient
appelé au boycott des élections
législatives
aujourd'hui 256 des 2 177 sièges sont
occupés par des élus proches du
gouvernement de nicholas maduro